aaa says drivers are inching a little  bit closer to embracing a new level of  technology  in cars in a survey they found that 58  percent of drivers want to see advanced  driver assistance systems or  adas in their cars those are things like  automatic emergency brake and lane  assistance  on the other hand 86 percent of drivers  would be afraid  to ride in an automated car we talked  briefly about that the other day brian  it's just like oh if there's something  happens  it's kind of hard when you're in the  back seat to try and salvage it you  would need to have superhero  arms that somehow extend to regain  control of the steering wheel how do you  get to the brake pedal  that's what i was thinking that's why  denise and i are in the 86 percent  we're gonna just keep driving this